it's critically important that the gop
regains majorities in both the house and
the senate in the fall
after two years of total democratic
control this country is falling apart
dangerously so look at the stock market
today it tanked yet again inflation at a
42-year high interest rates now going up
through the roof this is really crushing
everyone in this country especially the
poor the middle class uh our fellow
americans on fixed incomes and now top
economists are calling stagflation quote
unavoidable the ceo of wells fargo
saying there is no question bad days are
ahead analysts morgan stanley smart
people they're blaming the biden
administration for their inflation
and even far-left vox is blasting joe's
out-of-control spending and it gets even
worse today yet once again gas prices
shooting to the moon and today another
brand new record high uh price for a
gallon of gasoline in fact every day for
the past nine days gas prices set one
new record after another now this year
american families will have to for fork
over anywhere between five thousand two
hundred dollars to five thousand seven
hundred dollars and going higher thanks
to joe biden's inflation two thousand by
the way if you drive a car you're gonna
pay two thousand dollars more on average
just for gasoline this year over when
donald trump was president
and of course the administration likes
to blame all of our problems on
corporations and vladimir putin and
something they're calling ultra maga oh
you mean when gas prices were cheap the
border was under control where
warp speed actually worked and we didn't
run out of tests after two years uh and
every other disaster from afghanistan to
the war in europe this week biden's new
press secretary didn't seem to know uh
who who to blame or what to say it was
not a good start take a look
how does raising taxes on corporations
lower the cost of gas the cost of a used
car the cost of food for everyday
americans so look i think we encourage
those who have done very well right
especially those who care about climate
change
to support a fair attack tax code that
doesn't change that doesn't charge
manufacturers workers cops builders a
higher percentage of their earnings that
the most fortunate people in our nation
and not let this this that stand in the
way of reducing energy costs and
fighting this existential problem if you
think about that as an example and to
support basic collective bargaining
rights as well right that's also
important but look it is you know
by not if without having a fair tax code
which is what i'm talking about then all
every like manufacturing workers cops
you know it's not fair for them to have
to pay higher taxes than the folks that
who are who are who are not paying taxes
at all
forget that word salad you just heard
take a look at your screen look at
quinnipiac two percent that's right two
percent of americans now believe our
economy is in excellent shape and they
know just who to blame a whopping 63
percent blame joe biden
or ultra failure of a president want to
talk about ultra he's an ultra failure
by the way his approval rate look at
that is that 32
over the past year and a half as
americans have suffered from a supply
chain crisis now a baby formula shortage
spiking inflation spiking gas prices a
stock market in a free fall
the biden administration well they were
busy busy tackling the real crisis
disinformation in fact they spent a
considerable amount of time and energy
and effort to develop a brand new
ministry of truth that we've been
talking about to police all of your
thoughts we do have great news tonight
the ministry of truth or disinformation
governance board as it was coined is now
on pause and that far left lunatic
tapped to lead this shady new venture
has now resigned and as it turns out
former disinformation czar nina
jankowicz was one of the biggest
perpetrators and purveyors of
disinformation in the entire country now
she praised russian disinformation
dossier author christopher steele she
accused president trump of being a
russian plan she referred to the hunter
biden laptop scandal as a debunked trump
campaign product uh and like many other
prominent democrats nina jankowicz is a
conspiracy theorist who wants all
americans to believe her twisted
opinions and lies are facts now today
when asked about the disinformation
czar's resignation well biden's press
secretary was once again short on
answers take a look
so if it's pausing because you think the
board was mischaracterized then the
disinformation board is being shut down
because of disinformation is that what's
happening here look i mean the the board
was put forth for a purpose right to
make sure that we really did a uh really
did address what was happening across
the country when it came to
disinformation
it's just going it's it's going to pause
there's been a mischaracterizations from
outside
outside forces and so now what we're
going to do is going to we're going to
pause it and we're going to do an
assessment but the work does the work
doesn't stop we're still going to
continue the work
they're going to work so the is it alive
or is it gone anyway
does anyone in the biden administration
have a straight answer for anything do
they do they take any responsibility
have they ever heard of the phrase the
buck stops here now keep in mind even on
lucid days president biden is totally
incompetent his dhs secretary cares more
about policing your thoughts than
securing our border his treasury
secretary is a lunatic who told us
inflation was transitory his vice
president totally in over her head inept
and she never really seems to know what
she's talking about take a look
that is especially true when it comes to
the climate crisis which is why we will
work together and continue to work
together
to address these issues to tackle these
challenges
and to work together as we continue to
work
operating from the new norms rules and
agreements
that we will convene
to work together on
we'll all work together that's the plan
biden administration is a disaster on
every single level and november frankly
can't come soon enough hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else